Hello world,
it's a Raj.
And today I wanna talk about
a platform called trust token.
We're going to go over some code,
we're going to go over some theory,
we're going to go over how it works,
what it does, what's the point of it. Um,
and in the end I'm going to build a
solidity demo just to get you used to the
idea of a theory. I'm smart contracts,
which is what this is built on.
So I want to start off by saying
I was paid to make this video,
but I only said yes for two reasons.
Number one,
I personally know the founders and
I know they have good intentions.
And number two,
I actually believe in the products.
So the last paid video I made
was for Intel because again,
I believed in the product, the
movidius neural compute stick. Okay.
So I just want to make
that very clear before we,
before we get started with this.
Okay. So this is a cool product,
especially as somebody who has become a
bit disillusioned with the space because
of the amount of scams,
because of the scalability
issues with some platforms.
Because of the lack of regulations,
which is,
which are leading to a lot of people
losing a lot of money. So that's kind of,
you know, a few of the reasons I become
kind of disillusioned with the space.
But I like the idea of trust token.
I like where they're going with this.
Um, and so that's why I wanted
to talk about it today. Okay.
So what is the whole point
behind this? Well, okay,
so what it is is it's a platform to create
asset back tokens that you can easily
buy and sell around the world.
Okay.
So basically the idea is that you
can tokenize everything. Okay.
So real estate, oil, currencies,
your dog, your, you know,
any kind of physical object
in the real world, um, you
know, your house, et Cetera.
There's, there's so many things that
you could do, you know, your art pieces,
your music, et cetera. And so you
might be thinking, well, why would I,
why would I want to do that?
I could just put it on some
marketplace and sell it there. Well,
it turns out that not everybody has
access to investment opportunities.
And not everybody has access to the
ability to raise capital for this project.
And so what the idea of
tokenizing everything does
is it democratizes access to
capital. So anybody can raise
capital for their project, right? By,
by issuing these tokens, right?
So if I have some, you know,
house or something,
um,
I could then tokenize that house and allow
anybody to then share in ownership of
that house by issuing tokens. Right?
And so that's one. So the ability to,
uh, raise capital for,
you know, whatever it is.
The second great thing about this is
the ability to then invest in anything,
right? So think about Tesla
stock, right? So Tesla stock,
only certain people can invest in
Tesla, right? First of all, you,
ideally you're an American because
it's an American company listed on the
American Stock Exchange, right? So a
lot of people are not included, right?
They're not included in the ability to
purchase Tesla stock simply because they
weren't born in the United States,
right?
So democratizing access to investment
opportunities to everybody.
Then the ability to raise capital for
everybody is something that blockchain
technology and uh, an implementation of
it trust token or aiming to do. Okay.
So another thing is the idea of an ICO,
right?
So I see owes,
have kind of done that.
They've democratized the ability for
anybody to raise capital anywhere in the
world. But the problem is that
there are, there's no, you know,
regulatory legal framework
around all of this.
And this has resulted in a lot of scams,
right?
A lot of people losing a lot of money.
You don't necessarily have to be an
accredited investor to invest in any of
these ics, but you do in the
case of, uh, trust token,
right? So not necessarily an accredited
investor meeting of $1 million in, in,
in,
in capital,
but they definitely dotted their i's
and t's when it comes to the legal
documents, right? So they've listed
this, this coin on coin list, right? So
if we go to coin list.com we can see a
listing of there's trucks trust token
right there. There it is, right on the,
on the front page of coin list. Right?
So the only other coin
that I think is really,
really cool is file coin of
course. Because again, I know
Juan, he was my roommate.
IPFS is an incredible,
incredible protocol.
And file coin is kind of the glue
that makes IPFS work, right? So, and,
and you know that that's in progress,
but the whole idea behind establishing
coin list was to allow for there to be a
regulatory framework around the
ICO phenomenon, right? So the,
the saft is a,
is a document that was
drafted up specifically for
regulatory compliance with
the security and Exchange Commission,
the SEC and other regulatory
agencies within the United States.
And so if you want to do this,
this idea of an ICO the right way,
you should do it through coin list.
You should do it through the saft.
You should really be legal about it.
Okay.
Because that's the way we're going to
move forward. We have to, we can't just,
we can't just say, okay, there's a
government and there's this, you know,
everything is archaic. Let's just trash
it all and restart. Unfortunately,
that's not how it's gonna work right now.
Right.
We have to slowly bridge our way into
a world where everything is crypto in
digital, but we're not just going to be
able to say, oh, VR is of no use anymore.
That's not how it works. Okay,
so end of that little, you know,
little arguments right there.
So the idea is that trust Hokkien allows
you to tokenize everything, right? So,
and it's been listed on a bunch of,
you know, reputable exchanges, um,
listing the listing of them
is right here, uh, and it,
you can redeem it one
for one for a US dollar.
So one true USD token.
So trust token is the name of the platform
and the cryptocurrency is called true.
USD is worth one US dollar.
So it's a one to one mapping.
What that means is no volatility.
Let me say that again.
No volatility.
Okay.
So the plus side here is that you can now
have some cryptocurrency and not worry
that that value is going to diminish
by 30% in the next hour, right?
Because that's the case with a lot of
cryptocurrencies. But with this it,
because it's pegged to the dollar, you
know, you have that stability. The,
the con is that we are, hey, you
know, like ideologically speaking,
morally speaking in the,
the spectrum of decentralization
and crypto anarchism hey,
you are pegging your digital currency to
this beyond government backed currency.
The whole point is a, it's a
not do that eventually, right?
But we've got to build a bridge first
between the traditional financial world
and the crypto financial world. And what
trust token aims to do is just that.
Okay.
So the idea and the,
and the number they talk about is $256
trillion worth of real world assets.
A lot of it is in real estate, right?
So real estate homes, apartments, land,
this is,
these are not liquid assets.
Meaning no one can invest in
them directly in that way.
You can't trade a piece of a home,
right? Unless you can tokenize it.
And that's what this aims to do. So again,
the team, I know Rafael, I know Steven.
I know Danny, you know,
I met them around there.
They're bay area people and they're,
they're around Stanford, et Cetera.
They worked a kernel, which is a
brain computer interface startup.
When I say platform,
I mean there are five parts to the
system that they've created, right?
So every time you, you say, okay,
I want to tokenize this asset,
let's say it's my apartment.
A smart trust is created.
And so that's the first part.
A smart trust is a smart contract.
This is a solidity smart contract.
This was built on the
theory on blockchain.
And so what it does is it
appoints beneficial asset
ownership to the person who
then creates that a token, right?
So that's what the smart trust does.
The second part is trust market.
And what that does is it allows
clients to higher fiduciary.
So these are trusted third parties who
interfaced with the legal institutions
and are legally bound to manage assets
as instructed by the smart contract.
The Smart Trust,
the trust protocol is the set of
rules or the centralized rule set that
specifies how those smart
contracts can direct fiduciaries.
The trust volt is a decentralized storage
system for allowing for audit trails.
Remember we want to be very legal
about this for acid transactions.
And then lastly, the trust token was
the incentive layer at the very end,
which we're going to be able to use.
So if we look at the stack and it's
quite a big stack, they've, they've,
they've really thought this through,
right?
So you have your physical asset in the
real world, you know, you're, you know,
you're a art piece, your phone,
whatever you want to tokenize.
You have your legal entity on top of that.
That is that a smart
contract asset management.
This is happening in the
form of a trusted fiduciary.
Your Api on top of that that you can then
interact with.
And then you have a blockchain
layer, regulatory layer, um,
and then the staking layer, which
we're going to talk about in a second,
the staking layer.
So the first smart trust was issued
in October 17 and has a bank account.
This is the first time someone
tried to tokenize some product.
So if we go to either scan and we
type in that smart contract, a dress,
there we go. We can see it right
there. On the ethereum blockchain,
publicly verifiable by anybody.
And so normally you would think,
well, you know, there,
there's no need for this.
You would send money directly to the
entity that you want to exchange with and
they would then control it.
But when there's a trusted third
party that's not owned by a human,
but it's automated in the
form of a smart contract, uh,
it just makes the whole
transfer, um, less risky, right?
Because you're, you're automating
trust into this smart contract.
And so right now they
have a true USD token,
but they have plans to have one for euro,
the bond assets, et cetera. You know,
things like that,
different currencies.
But right now they have one that's
pegged to the USD [inaudible] currency.
So, and there's a very, there's very
much a need for a stable cryptocurrency.
Look at this chart of, of,
uh, of Bitcoin's price, uh,
over a period of a year or two.
This is way too volatile for anything
useful as a currency, right? Or A,
as a store of value.
So, uh, a store of, of,
of stable value that is,
okay. So, and, and look,
uh,
trust token is not the only token out
there that's trying to have a one to one
mapping with the u s dollar tether
is currently the largest [inaudible]
collateralized cryptocurrency.
But there they have no legal guarantees
that those tether coins can be redeemed
for traditional currency,
right?
So the whole point of this is to allow
both the investor and the PR and the
entity that they are investing
in to breathe a sigh of
relief and know that they
can trust the idea of
tokenizing their assets,
that they're not going to
lose their money. That's the
whole point of regulation,
right? We are rebuilding regulation
in a way around this, this,
this whole crypto space. Uh,
so, so, so they, they, you know,
the drafted up the saft, they,
um, they're listed on coin list.
You go through a form and you have to
list out some information about your
investor status to be able to invest.
So they've really gone through the steps
necessary to make sure that the sec is
happy with them.
And I think this is an example that the
rest of the space should be following.
Okay.
So what are the use cases of this?
So we know that one use case is
to tokenize your assets, right?
Another use case is to have
a stable cryptocurrency for
buying and selling goods,
right? You know, it's great
to be able to use bitcoin,
but you don't know how much
that bitcoin is going to be,
that you can use this to buy things
where digital currencies are accepted.
And because it's built on top of the
ethereum blockchain using the Erc 20
framework, you know the, and
I have a great video on that.
It's called initial point offering Saroj
search out on Youtube of how Erc 20
works,
but because it's an Erc 20 token,
his backwards compatible with all
services that accept etherium, right?
So there's that and you could store it
in your etherium wallet because you know,
all Erc 20 tokens are backwards
compatible with each other.
So let's get to the fun part,
right? The architecture,
which there's not a lot of information
on it, but that's why I'm here for you.
Okay. So, so the idea is this, they're
there. It's two procedures here.
There's a by procedure and
there's a cell procedure.
Let's go over the by procedure. Okay? So
how do we do this? Right? So if we want,
if we have a hundred US dollars and we
wanted to exchange that for a hundred
true USD tokens,
here's how it works.
The first step is for us to be able
to complete KYC and AML compliance.
What that means is know your customer
and um, what does AML stand for?
Anti money laundering,
right?
So these are standard forms that
the sec needs to make sure that uh,
no one's getting screwed over, okay?
That, that's essentially what it is.
And so what once you complete those,
um,
trust tokens team is going to manually
review that, make sure that it works,
then you will submit that
Info, uh, in the form of you,
you're going to have
your ethereum address.
You're going to take that
a theory I'm address,
and you're going to provide
it to the trust token team.
Then you're going to wire
funds to a trusted third
party. And this is an escrow.
It's called Prime Trust.
It's a Nevada based company.
Once you wire those funds
directly to them, uh,
both them as an escrow and a group of
what are called stakers are going to
verify the validity of your transaction
and then a smart contract is going to be
activated. The will then immediately
receive some true USD tokens. Okay,
so there are two checks here,
right? Checks and balances.
The first is the fact that they have this
third party escrow called Prime Trust,
which is a company,
a trust based company as whole job is
to validate transactions. So that's one.
The second is a group of
stakers. So, and right now, um,
they have a few stakers and what the
stakers are is every time you make a
transaction in this networked, 10% of
that transaction is given to the stakers.
And the stakers job is to verify
the validity of transactions, right?
So when it comes to, and I have
this, I had this proof of stake,
a infographic here where you have
a group of people who are verifying
transactions and the network
based on how much stake they have.
And so what this is,
is it,
it's an additional consensus algorithm
on top of the theorems already existing
proof of work and then they will
transition to proof of stake.
But this is just as a way of
further validating that transaction,
which is good for both, both the person
who is trying to get those tokens.
It's good for all parties involved
because it adds a layer of trust to
everything. Okay, so, so
that's the first part of,
so stakers and the escrow. And we're going
to go into this code in second. Okay.
So that's the buy part. The cell
part looks like this, right?
So if you want to use
the trust token platform,
you'll create this smart trust contract.
You issue the title of
the asset to the trust,
and then you'll lock up that trust and
then you can distribute your asset tokens
to anybody who wants to then buy your
asset. Okay? So that was for how to buy.
Let's talk about how to sell,
right?
So when you want to sell
your true USD tokens,
the first step is to burn them,
okay? So what do I mean by burn?
So the idea of burning coins,
what that really means,
and this is an example right here,
is that you're sending them
to an address that nobody has.
The private key to those coins
don't just magically disappear.
What happens is they go to
a locked account that nobody
has the private keys of.
And once the smart contract has verified
that the funds have been transferred to
that public key,
then the service is notified that hey,
these coins have been burned, a boolean
value. And so once you burned your tokens,
the stakers,
we'll verify that transaction and then
you will receive Fiat's from this trusted
third party and you will receive fee
out from a prime trust and then you will
receive your true USC Tokens. Okay, so,
so that's the basic
idea of how that works.
You a user submits a wire to the company
with the crypto wallet information.
They'll send the signal to Tura,
USDS,
smart contract and verifying you purchase
it. And then automatically, you know,
just the whole idea of a smart
contract is that it's automatic.
They get the signal and they'll
send out this funds. Okay.
And so what it looks like when you
actually buy that, once you add,
verify your identity,
you're a theory and address or email,
you can then deposit USC and withdraw
Usd using this very nice graphical user
interface. Okay, so let's get into
the code here for a second. Okay.
So first of all,
I want to talk about how easy it is
to build smart contracts. Okay? It's,
it's very easy to build smart contracts
and not a lot of people appreciate that
fact. Okay? So what we're gonna be using
right now is the theory, some remix a ID.
This is in the browser. Anybody can
compile, run tests there, solidity,
smart contracts.
So I want to build a very simple one
here called a creator balance checker.
And this is just a smart contract that's,
that's able to record the
address and the amount that,
that the person who created the
contract has in their account, right?
So I'm going to create a
contract and that contract,
we'll be able to tell anybody
who then calls it, how much, um,
crypto I have and the address of
the person who created it. Okay? So,
and they use something like this
whenever you're trying to buy a coin.
And we'll get into that. But I want to
start off with a very simple example here.
Okay.
So
we're gonna start off with a contract
called Creator Balance Checker Creator
Balance Checker. This is a
solidity smart contract. Okay?
And so what it's gonna do is going to
record two parameters. The address of me,
the person created the contract and
the amount that I have that's called my
creator balance.
By the way,
you int is an alias for you into two 56.
It's a 256 bit integer.
Okay? So there's that and now I'm going
to create that balance checker function,
right? So creator balance, checker
functioning, it's a public function.
Anybody can access it. Um,
and so what it says is, okay,
who is the creator
and what is their balance?
And so this is basically
the constructor function.
That's a signs, these values, whenever
the creator creates it, right?
So that's it. That's all it
is. And so once we have that,
now we can get to the fun stuff.
Now we can say,
let's get that contract address.
So, uh, whoever, then Kohl's,
this smart contract is
going to be able to,
is going to be able to then return to
receive what that contract addresses.
Now we can do the same thing for get
the Creator's balance. And again,
we're making this very
simple function to do this.
We also want to make sure that
this is going to return a you ENT.
And speaking of what we want to return,
we want to make sure
this returns the address,
okay? And now we simply just returned
that this isn't just a simple get method,
right? It's a simple get a in the
if we went and go back to https,
a rest idea. Okay. And so now, well,
there's also one more
thing I want to do here.
So we're not just getting
the Creator's balance.
We want to get the creators
two types of balance.
So we want to get the Creator's current
balance and we want to get the creator's
balance at the time
that they created this,
this smart contract. Okay?
So this is going to return,
is going to return, it's going to
return. And this is going to be a you int
return creator adopt
balance. Okay. And so,
so this first one is going to
return it at the time of creation.
And this is going to return the
current balance, which is very cool.
So it can actually
return both across time.
And I want to have one
more a function here.
So let's just say we want
to recover funds, right? So
as long as I'm the creator,
I can recover my funds by doing
this for the smart contract,
I can create a kill
function that will say, hey,
if the person who calls this function,
if the messages,
if the message is sender is the
creator of this smart contract,
then go ahead and kill the contract and
send the remaining funds to the creator.
So I'll say called suicide creator.
Okay. Um, there's that the de,
and now I can close this smart contract.
And so now I can start to compile.
I want to see what errors I
have here. Created a balance.
Great. Start to compile.
Okay. It looks good. It looks good.
And now inside of my javascript Vn,
I will now deploy this.
And now I have deployed
this smart contract to this
test and test net and now I
can check it out. And so now what this
does, this guy here is it kind of,
it simulates,
you can do this from console as well,
but we're doing it via this graphical
user interface where I am now calling the
smart contract,
get the contract address.
So that's the address of
the Creator who created it.
And that's me calling that that function.
Let me do the same for the balance,
okay?
That's how much money the creator has.
And you can see that's exactly the
amount I have in my account here.
And now lastly, I'll do the
same thing for the balance now,
which is going to be a little less right.
And now the last function
I'm going to call his kill.
And that kills that smart contract. Now
what? Now that I killed it, if I go back,
of course everything's going
to fail because that's smart
contract doesn't exist.
Okay?
So I just wanted to give you a simple
smart contract example that can compile
and run for you to see how easy
it is to create these things.
So now let's look at their smart
contracts. So they've got this, uh,
get hub repository with a bunch
of different smart contracts. Um,
and so what I've done is I've kind of
like dawn through them and tried to, uh,
decipher what, what the smart
contracts do, what part does what,
um,
and so basically we can say that,
uh,
for when it comes to buying a token,
you have your compliant token dot Sol
fall and your time log dot Sol file. Okay,
so here,
are there a smart contracts?
Okay, so there's a lot. So if
we go to the highest level,
if we go to the highest level here,
and so they're using open Zeplin great
architectural choice to use open Zeppelin
for, uh, templates to easily create these
smart Erc 20 smart contracts. Great idea.
So true.
USC is the highest level smart contract
they have and it inherits from their
other smart contracts. Modular PauseAble
token, no honer burnable token.
It's a compliant token. It's a token
with fees. It's, it's a withdrawal token.
It's a standard delegates,
it can delegate. So all of
these features, you know,
you can withdraw, it has fees,
it's compliant or inherited.
And to go to this master class
master contract, true USD.
And so in the constructor
it is in the constructor,
it is talking about how many tokens or
are in total, how many are being burned,
et cetera. And then you're going
to change the token name, you know,
different things like that. And you've
got a bunch of a helper methods here,
but it's actually a
very small contract for,
for what it does because everything is
really inherited from other classes.
So KYC and AML compliance.
So what is happening here is it's a
manual review by the trust token team.
And this is a string that
holds that boolean value has
a passed or not. They can,
they can then modify that.
So then once this boolean value is set
to true that you've passed, you know,
the next step in the process
is activated automatically,
right?
So the compliant token is all about
storing that value in particular.
And so this is all about buying.
Okay?
So the second really important
part is time locked controller.
So think about the possibilities here.
You can miss the network,
can mint a token,
the network can burn some tokens,
the network can request for
some tokens to be transferred.
And all of this depends on a Timelock,
right? So has the person sent this money?
Okay, go ahead and do this. Has
a person burned this Hogan, okay,
go ahead and do this and that,
that code is in this Timelock controller.
You can even see that
staking fees can be changed.
You can change the person who is able
to stake, uh, you can switch roles.
So certain people can, you know, have
certain permissions to do certain things.
So there's a lot of permissions
here, but they, all, all of it is,
is inherited true USD,
inheritance, all of it. Um,
that's when it comes to buying a token.
When it comes to selling a token,
you've got this burnable token dot Sol.
And what this does is it simply
burns a token, right? So that, that,
that's all it does, right? When you,
when you say, okay, you know what,
I want to trade my true USD token for
some us dollar, you are then using this,
uh, uh, solidity file to send that token
to nowhere that no one has access to.
And then once, uh, the
network realizes that, hey,
this person has burned this
token, then we're going to, um,
delegate access to real,
you know,
USD Fiat currency and that
transaction will be completed. Okay.
So that's how that works. This
is a cool, very cool project.
I think we can learn a lot
from this project by looking
at the way that they did
things in illegal a way,
which is a good thing. Uh,
and also just the fact that they
seem to have very clean code.
This is a good contract design pattern
to have a high level contract and then
other features that are inherited
into that high level contract. Okay.
So I hope you found this video useful.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos and for now I've got to tokenize,
so thanks for watching.